cameras aren't working that's getting
super frustrating this is what it's like
I went below zero cameras are down tough
conditions all around a fill-in
no heat no power do anything won't even
turn on
yeah Baggins this is a typical day in
the Arctic
they confessed what we got I built this
time lag slot box that what we're going
to do with this one is try and catch the
freezer I love doing stuff like this now
they're trying to get live different
shots and shot says maybe we haven't
seen before like I'm late freezing up
and a nice clear I think these kind of
specialty type shots some of the most
fun part of this whole being involved in
this program I just really get a kick
out of trying to experiment and do new
things and so this is a big part of that
he's still pretty good for level this is
completely enclosed and this is
waterproof too so there it should be
good to go and be able to stand all
conditions we've got a solar panel
hooked up to a battery that ideally was
gonna keep charging this camera and it
can run for as long as it can
she said she's going
[Music]
well we're trying to do is set up a
really long time left so that we have
the yukon breaking up so we're just
looking for that
visual that looks out over the river if
you take a second look at it and it
doesn't look right then let's not do it
bye guys be safe on that little night
bridge
the safety guy and the director of
photography just left they're up there
right now getting dropped off and
basically a nice edge of a peak
I am really excited a little bit nervous
[Music]
gonna take a couple of car batteries to
run the camera so that it doesn't quit
on us because we only have one
opportunity to get this time-lapse and
we think it's gonna happen in this
two-week window and ice of the frozen
Yukon River breaks up because my job is
cool yeah it is
[Music]